[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idée qui gouverne le
monde djihadisme Sud global Occident le
nouvel archipel
mondial
incontestablement nous vivons un regain
d'activité du djihadisme mondial alors
que l'on pensait en avoir fini avec
daesh cet état islamique qui fut défait
militairement mais dont les
ramifications djihadistes demeurent
extrêmement
inflammabl devons-nous nous préparer à
vivre avec ce djihadisme
d'atmosphère selon l'expression
judicieuse de l'historien Gilles kppel
cette préoccupation géostratégique s'est
considérablement amplifiée depuis le 7
octobre 2023 avec l'invasion terroriste
du sud d'Israël par le Hamas et la
ripost israélienne contre le territoire
Gazaoui quoi qu'en pense les belles
consciences et les bonnes âmes de
l'avèement de la paix universelle des
nations le monde est plus conflictualisé
que jamais il se retrouve clivé dans un
partage géostratégique entre le bloc des
démocraties occidentale et une
constellation d'État regroupant la Chine
la Russie l'Iran entre autres et que
l'on nomme aujourd'hui le sud global
bref nous assistons à un renforcement de
la polarisation politique de la planète
entre régime autoritaire et Démocratie
libérale à ce sujet on peut s'interroger
si le conflit en Ukraine et celui du
ramas en Israël puis à Gaza ne relève
pas d'une même guerre au même moment
l'Europe et le théâtre d'assassinat
terroriste perpétré par la mouvance
islamiste très présente sur les réseaux
sociaux en ravivant qui les plaies du
colonialisme qui les PL de l'indigénisme
de l'antisémitisme et de la
universelle des valeurs héritées des
lumières doit-on en conclure que le
djihadisme veut la peau de la
civilisation des lumières et si c'était
le cas à quelle fin idéologique
religieuse et sociétale pour tenter d'y
répondre je vous présente mes invités
Benoît d'abauville vous êtes diplomate
ancien ambassadeur auprès de l'OTAN him
elkoui vous êtes consultant et
esséiste Florence Bergeot blackler vous
êtes docteur en anthropologie et chargé
de recherche au CNRS Patrick Kessel vous
êtes journaliste et ancien grand maître
du Grand Orient de
[Musique]
France des attentats du 11 septembre
2001 à New York au khalifat islamique de
DAEs défit aujourd'hui aux attentats en
Europe à la guerre du 7 octobre 2023
déclenchée par le ramas est-ce que vous
diriez que cet enchaînement conflictuel
résulte d'une commune activité
stratégique terroriste guerrière d'un
djihadisme mondial Benoît d'abauville je
je crois qu'il faut apporter pas mal de
nuances au concept de Sud global parce
que ce sont des pays euh très différents
qui ont des des intérêts très différents
mais qui ont trouvé dans euh la
revendication contre disons l'Occident
et une cause commune qui est appuyée par
opportunisme politique notamment par
Monsieur Poutine mais aussi par les
chinois alors cela dit je crois qu'il
faut euh éviter de confondre cette
euh cette querelle en quelque sorte
politique qui euh occupe véritablement
toute le toute la presse les débat au
nations- Unies et cetera avec euh disons
les
euh les problèmes disons de de
différenceces culturelles et surtout
religieuses vous vous souvenez de des
thèses de du du politiste américain
Huntington qui disait nous allons vers
une guerre de civilisation moi je crois
que nous allons vers un monde tout à
fait désordonné où il n'y a plus de il y
a plus de puissance qui
euh mettre de l'ordre dans le jardin
d'enfant multilatéral si vous voulez euh
mais euh qui n'est pas mais qui va dans
dans avec des conflits d'intérêts de
niveau très très différents alors le le
jihadisme c'est une bon c'est aussi des
nuances hein euh c'est c'est d'abord un
conflit au Proche Orient alors que la
revendication disons du Sud global elle
est plutôt d'ordre économique politique
et et donc pas tellement sur
lein des des religions elle est pas
civilisationnelle dans la haine de
l'Occident non mais la haine de
l'Occident elle est elle est liée non
pas à à la l'attaque contre l'Europe des
Lumières ou les états i
interventionniste elle est elle est
c'est une revendication de pouvoir
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas reçu
dans la communauté internationale euh
l'audience et et surtout le poids
politique et qui nous revient de
aujourd'hui les pays du Sud représentent
dans le le le poids de l'économie
mondiale
euh quelque chose qui ne correspond pas
à leur poids dans la diplomatie
mondiale les institutions
internationales elles ont été fond
organisées en 45 le monde a changé
depuis 45 bien Hakim elkaroui là-dessus
alors en fait il y a deux questions il y
a la question du djihadisme il y a la
question du Sud global sur le djihadisme
j'apporterai une petite nuance à ce que
vous disiez je crois qu'il y a ces deux
organisations différentes mais Al-Qaïda
2001 et puis daesh on est dans un on est
dans un un système messianique on est
dans un système où le territoire compte
assez peu ce qui compte c'est le projet
politique la vision idéologique et la
construction d'une idéologie globale le
Hamas c'est pas un projet messianique le
Hamas c'est un sujet d'abord territorial
avec une couche religieuse une couche
idéologique une couche de haine mais
dans un cas DAEs Al-Qaïda on est on est
sur une affirmation idéologique d'abord
dans l'autre cas le Hamas on est sur une
revendication territorial contre un
ennemi très identifié avec et c'est ça
qui est nouveau des méthodes qui sont
qui sont les mêmes qui sont très proches
mais il faut pas mettre dans le même sac
euh Hakim elkaroui l'invasion du Hamas
en Israël s'est faite avec un un slogan
très précis tuer des Juifs c'est ce que
je vous dis c'est que la méthode la
méthode et c'est ça qui est nouveau dans
le le le le 7 octobre dans l'attaque
terroriste du 7 octobre la méthode est
la même mais le projet politique la la
vision du monde n'est pas la même dans
un cas on on a un sujet qui est avec le
Hamas on a on a une problématique qui
est circonstancié à un territoire et
dans l'autre on a une vision messianique
globale
téléologique et et qui vis d'une
certaine manière à la fin des temps donc
en fait on parle de deux choses qui sont
très différentes pour vous avec des
méthodes qui sont proches et pour vous
Madame Bergeot becckler peut-être qu'on
peut commencer par définir les termes
c'est vrai que bon djihad c'est la
guerre sainte la guerre sainte elle se
mène de de plusieurs manières elle se
mène si si je peux me permettre en arabe
djihad c'est il y a plusieurs
significations c'est la voix sur le
chemin de Dieu oui c'est pas seulement
la guerre sainte c'est c'est beaucoup de
choses mais disons qu'aujourd'hui on
parle de géopolitique on parle
d'affrontement on parle bien de guerre
sainte donc le djihad c'est la guerre
sainte qui est menée soit militairement
avec les branches djihadistes soit par
le droit ou contre les libertés par les
libertés on voit cette citation de de
erdoan euh les démocraties contre
elles-mêmes de de d'une certaine manière
pour ensuite les les conquérir et donc
cette forme euh de de djihad de de
pression psychologique de pression
politique s'appelle l'islamisme
légaliste mais en réalité toutes ces
toutes ces branches djihadistes ou
islamisme légaliste proviennent d'une
seule matrice qui est celle des Frères
musulmans les Frères musulmans eux-mêmes
ne sont pas nés comme ça ils sont nés
euh d'une réaction du monde musulman à
l'abolition du califat à la disparition
du califat qui a été un énorme
traumatisme dans le monde musulman donc
c'est important d'avoir cette ce recul
historique pour essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe et notamment le Hamas c'est
quoi c'est une réislamisation parce
qu'en fait le conflit territorial a été
islamisé dans les années 20 30 par le
moufti de Jérusalem et puis il y a une
réislamisation à nouveau de ce conflit
avec l'arrivée du Hamas c'est-à-dire
grosso modo les années 80 qui ont vu qui
qui ont suivi le triomphe de l'État
islamique iranien et qui a donné une
espèce de force à tous les mouvements de
l'islam politique dont le le Hamas qui
est une branche des Frères musulmans
mais qui bien sûr a une importance
particulière puisqu'il est un petit peu
les Gard les gardiens des lieux saints
de l'Islam puisque Jérusalem est
considéré comme un lieu saint donc c'est
dans cette là qu'il faut poser le
problème je crois une perspective longue
de de la de la revanche califal oui
Patrick Kessel sur ce continuum vous
pensez que tout ça
se il y a une logique une
cohérence je pense qu'il est difficile
de pas voir une continuité
dans ses comportement
successif la poudre encore flambé il y a
pas très longtemps donc c'est difficile
de de considérer qu'on peut avec recul
avoir un point de vue objectif donc je
saurais pas répondre à à cette
question simplement c'est vrai que on
est dans dans une phase
d'incontinuité
d'incontinuité et de de méconnaissance
de ce qui
peutevenir je vois aussi
les les informations que nous pouvons
avoir
de gens qui vivent en territoire
israélien ou en
territoire
aujourd'hui très partagé qu'on trouve
entre Israël et d'autres régions qui
sont proches j'avoue qu'aujourd'hui
j'avoue d'ailleurs trouver une une
immense médiocrité dans les commentaires
de mes confrères
euh je trouve que dans l'ensemble les
informations qui sont données sont
hachées sont et qu'on ne sait pas
trop qui dit quoi dedans où où en est-on
aujourd'hui je je vois dans certain
regard un étonnement c'est vrai qu'on
est plus du tout dans une phase de
compréhension distance conflictuelle je
sais pas trop j'aimerais bien vous
entendre aussi sur ce oui mais
l'information est dans l'instantané donc
les images encore plus que le reste
sûrement mais oui on est face à une
situation extrêmement complexe je je
crois que on peut pas considérer que le
sud global
euh travaille avec l'islamisme hein
l'islamisme peut ajouter mais le SU
global vous avez des vous avez des gens
qui sont absolument anti-islam à
commencé par les Chinois les Chinois dét
oui mais personne ne leur reproche ça
oui mais mais dans le dans l'efficacité
même quand ils font l'puration ethnique
personne ne dit on n'a jamais vu la
moindre manifestation euh pas plus en
France qu'ailleurs il a il y a quelques
comp sur l'affaire des des Ouigours il y
a quand même des des gens qui qui
protestent mais vous vous n'avez aucune
euh les les Russes et les Chinois euh
politique
veulent changer le système international
bon et donc il s'appuie sur ce qui leur
paraît utile mais Poutine il il n'aime
pas du tout les islamistes la guerre en
tchenie c'est C c'est vraiment une une
offensive
cont encore récemment encore
récemment le régime de Poutine par
exemple a décidé de s'attaquer aux
valeurs démocratiques en limitant
l'IVG en pénalisant le mouvement LGBT
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une attaque des
valeurs VO que Poutine que Poutine soit
antidémocratique et antidémocrate ça on
le sait malheureusement depuis longtemps
et on le voit aujourd'hui et il en fait
un argument et notamment pour s'appuyer
sur sur la droite en Europe mais moi je
je parler de la distinction entre le sud
global et son offensive contre les
structures du
international une revendication de
pouvoir alors ce n'est pas Bandou ce n
pas les non alignés
les l'Arabie Saoudite c'est pas un pays
pauvre donc c'est et c'est un pays qui
n'a pas été colonisé donc si vous voulez
il y a une très grande diversité dans la
notion du Sud global et donc je crois
qu'il faut bien distinguer entre les
problèm de l'islamine et les problèmes
du Proche Orient qui et et le la
question
du Sud global qui est en réalité le
poids de
l'Occident dans les années qui viennent
très bien alors écoutez on va distinguer
entre les différentes étapes Hakim
elkaroui pour parler on va commencer par
l'islamisme si on prend quel certaines
réflexions qui datent de plus de d'un
demi-siècle André malerau considérit que
la violence de la pensée islamique je le
cite est le grand FA phénomène de notre
époque George sprun un grand résistant
considéit que l'islamisme est le 3isem
totalitarisme du 20e siècle est-ce que
vous pensez que l'offensive
islamiste d'aujourd'hui est en
continuité par ses modes d'action et ses
particularités avec cet islam politique
dénoncé à la fois par André mallerud et
George sprun et dans ce cas quoi
attribuez-vous à quoi attribuez cette
permanence parce que c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui et des personnages que je
je cite ne sont pas des
extrémistes non enfin je pense que
personne n considéré que l'islamisme
était une idéologie
Pacifique donc ça fait longtemps que le
la problématique est identifiée
l'islamisme a une caractéristique c'est
que ça mute il y a il y a à la fois des
éléments qui sont toujours les mêmes et
en gros l'idéologie a été formalisée
vous le disiez madame Bergeot blackcller
il y a un siècle dans les années 20 euh
il y a les Frères musulmans en Égypte il
y a le mouvement des oulema en Algérie
euh et donc il y a une vision du monde
où il s'agit d'islamiser il faut
islamiser le monde donc faut islamiser
la lecture du monde ça c'est l'idéologie
puis après il y a des moyens qui varient
beaucoup il y a des moyens légau
effectivement plutôt ceux des Frères
musulmans il y a des des moyens que l'on
dit piétistes c'est-à-dire ultra
religieux et donc aussi ultra
réactionnaire on parle par très peu
aujourd'hui du salafisme salafisme a à
mon avis beaucoup plus d'importance en
France aujourd'hui que les Frères
musulmans sachant que maintenant on est
passé à de nouvelles générations qui
font un mélange entre les deux et qui
voit plus qui voit plus la différence
entre une tradition plus politique des
frères et puis une une tradition plus
religieuse des salafistes et puis il y a
eu les mouvements terroristes et puis il
y en a eu plusieurs des mouvements
terroristes on parlait d'alqïda on
parlait de daesh c'est pas du tout les
mêmes c'est pas du tout la même matrice
idéologique le Hamas c'est encore
différent euh donc il y a une permanence
qu'il y a une vision du monde il y a des
moyens d'action qui sont différents il y
a une temporalité qui est différente les
problématiques sont sont pas les mêmes
en même temps à l'évidence c'est une
idéologie violente dangereuse et puis
dans un certain nombre de cas subversive
au sens où on sait pas très bien où elle
est moi je dis que l'islamisme c'est une
idéologie plastique elle s'adapte à elle
s'adapte à son environnement après il
faut faire attention on peut être
musulman et conservateur on n'est pas
pour pour autant islamiste donc il faut
il faut je pense dans le le débat
l'analyse être être assez prudent parce
que on a vite fait de consider que tout
musulman est un
islamiste pour vous Madame Bergeot
blcl comment vous voyez cette peut-être
qu'il faut que je je précise un peu d'où
je parle donc moi je suis anthropologue
he pas pas géopoliticienne pas politiste
pas
esséiste la première fois que j'ai
rencontré les Frères musulmans c'était
il y a 30 ans à la mosquée de Bordeaux
là où ici taré coubro donc je connais
assez bien les Frères musulmans de
l'intérieur je connais j'ai pu suivre
leur parcours leur influence aussi sur
la la le les normativités islamiques
contemporaines et il faut reconnaître
qu'aujourd'hui les Frères musulmans euh
qui sont héritiers pas seulement de la
branche de Hassan elbana la branche
arabe qui a donné assassad Hassan Albana
Saïd cut ou ou yousseph el kardaoui mais
aussi la branche indopakistanaise qui
joue un rôle très important et notamment
sur le marché halal euh des normativités
islamiques donc qui est celle de maudoui
et ce ce cette rencontre qui a été
rendue possible par le père de Tarik
Ramadan donc Saïd Ramadan et est
aujourd'hui ce que j'appelle le frérisme
qui est une
idéologie qui est plus large que la
seule application des préceptes de la
confrériie qui est né il y a un siècle
donc déjà ça c'est ça c'est une première
chose je pense pense que aujourd'hui les
le frérisme est dominant dans est
hégémonique dans le paysage religieux
islamique français et européen en
général le frérisme c'est un salafisme
il y a plusieurs salafismes mais le
frérisme est un des salafises qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire le salafisme c'est ceux
qui se réfèrent aux pieux anciens
c'est-à-dire au au prophètes et à ses
compagnons et qui en ont fait un modèle
d'imitation donc ça c'est vrai aussi
bien des salafistes wahabites euh dont
je pense il a été question et aussi des
frères qui sont euh alors la différence
entre les les wabites et les les
fréristes c'est que les wabites sont des
gens du texte donc il travaillent le
texte et il leur faudrait idéalement
revenir dans les pays musulmans faire la
hijra alors que les frères sont des gens
du texte et du contexte et donc il
travaille le contexte pour l'adapter au
texte ce que ne font pas les d'autres et
ça c'est c'est c'est c'est fondamental
comme différence euh les les frères
aujourd'hui en Europe sont les premiers
réformistes réformiste du du de de la
pensée théologique et réformiste du
contexte c'est-à-dire ce qu'il veulent
faire c'est ce qu'ils ont toujours dit
d'ailleurs islamiser la modernité et moi
je traduis ça par rendre la société
charia compatible et aujourd'hui pour
être musulman et avoir une approche
relativement libérale
euh qui aurait dû d'ailleurs exister en
nombre beaucoup plus important dans une
société sécularisée libérale c'est très
difficile parce que le rôle des Frères
musulmans c'est d'empêcher la fitna dans
la communauté musulmane c'est de
conduire le mouvement islamique c'est ce
que kardaoui disait il voulait créer un
mouvement islamique qui donc serait
composé de l'ensemble des composantes du
paysage religieux des des djihadistes
aux plus libéraux pour les conduire vers
la la le le califat pour construire le
califat donc c'est pas une chapelle le
frérisme c'est c'est un c'est c'est ce
que moi j'appelle un système d'action
oui alors Patrick
Kessel dans ce grand sud il y a pas que
l'islamisme il y a des grandes
puissances comme la Chine la Russie et
d'autres pays on parle on laisse l'Iran
de côté on va en parler après à votre
avis pourquoi la Chine la Russie et
d'autres pays activent cette notion
Grand Sud pour s'opposer à l'Occident
est-ce une revanche de civilisation
pourquoi ils en veulent à
l'Occident c'est une bonne question
ou mais c'est une bonne question comment
pourrais-jey répondre d'un point de vue
personnel non mais nous assistons
aujourd'hui à une recomposition si c'est
ce que suggère ta ta question on est
dans un contexte qui c'est'est
profondément modifié et quand on parle
aussi avec des amis qui vivent en
Afrique qui vivent au
ProcheOrient c'est sûr que cette
approche est très différente de la nôtre
en même temps il y a beaucoup
d'incertitude il y a beaucoup
d'inquiétude je ne saurais pas répondre
à ce j'aimerais avoir les mains pleines
de vérité dire
voilà voilà comment faudrait faire
comment faut
faire simplement il y a une
recomposition des territoires et des
cultures qui n'est pas au bout de ses
peines vous voyez ça monsieur d'bauville
comme une revanche de civilisation estce
que ils estiment qu'ils ont été
ils ont c'est c'est c'est
l'utilisation de certains thèmes
politiques et idéologiques pourrou ouver
un pouvoir donc ils estiment qu'ils ont
été perdus pour les Chinois c'est très
simple ils considèrent qu'il était une
grande civilisation et qui qu'on n pas
et qu'ils ont perdu le pouvoir
international ils sont membres du
Conseil de sécurité mais disons au cours
des des 50 dernières années ils n'ont
pas joué le rôle qu'ils
estiment devoir être le leur
alors leur rôle c'est d'être c'est
d'être une des trois puissance mondiale
qui ils le sont ils sont même la deuxème
puissance oui mais c'est c'est c'est
c'est récent parce qu'ils ont accédé ils
ont fait un effort extraordinaire de
développement économique et maintenant
ils disent écoutez ben on n plus dans le
monde de 45 et donc il faut il faut le
changer Poutine pour des raisons
opportunistes c'est rallé ça mais si
vous voulez entre entre
leur leur
différentes recherches de pou voir il y
a beaucoup de nuances alors moi j'étaéis
très intéressé par les différentes
nuances que vous avez mentionné sur sur
les courants islamistes mais voulez vous
constatz que ils sont appuyés au Proche
Orient par des puissances qui
elles-mêmes s'opposent entre elles il y
a y a l'Arabie Saoudite ou ou l'Iran ont
des clientèles très différentes est-ce
que vous accordez et reg regardez
regardez la situation entre le Liban et
la Syrie c'est c'est c'est véritablement
ils ont des ils ont des patrons qui qui
sont différents mais qui pour des
raisons
conjoncturel qui durent ou qui dureront
pas aboutissent à ce qu'il y ait des des
protections de l'argent des armes qui
vont au différents acteurs des qui sont
qui profitent du désordre moyenoriental
oui alors akimal oui là-dessus et aussi
sur la la question de l'Iran est-ce que
vous croyez que le chisme entre sunnit
et chiit soit une réalité aujourd'hui
j'ai j'ai entendu de des diplomates
saoudiens
s'inquiéter de d'une revendication
iranienne sur les lieux saints autrement
dit ça reviendrait
à un conflit un peu historique entre euh
qui date de plusieurs siècles est-ce que
à votre avis qu'est-ce que cherche
l'Iran aujourd'hui au-delà du conflit au
Moyen-Orient avec le Hamas le Hezbollah
les outi mais quelle est sa stratégie
aujourd'hui au-delà de opposition à
Israël c'est c'est moins l'Iran que le
régime iranien euh l'Iran vous sa le
régime il a perdu sa population depuis
depuis un certain temps et notamment ces
femmes ce qu'on voit depuis depuis 2 ans
euh je crois le régime iranien sa
stratégie est assez simple il est dans
un mode défensif il essaie d'exister de
se maintenir au pouvoir coûte que coûte
avec une dimension idéologique qui est
toujours présent dans le discours mais
maintenant on parle surtout d'intérêt
d'intérêt personnel d'intérêt des passes
d'arang d'intérêt d'éclair et cetera et
comment il essaie de se maintenir au
pouvoir en créant de des problèmes dans
tout son environnement en étant agressif
dans tout son environnement pour essayer
de construire une sorte de GLA
protecteur et donc c'est en Irak en
Syrie au Liban au Yémen tout autour de
son adversaire régional qui est
l'adversaire saoudien et puis il y a son
adversaire mondial que sont les
États-Unis mais euh les les Iraniens ils
ont perdu leur vocation messianique ils
l'ont perdu en fait depuis 40 ans depuis
la guerre contre l'Irak qui s'est soldé
par une sorte de match nul mais qui les
a considérablement affaiblis la
révolution islamique mondiale c'était
surtout les wahabites c'est eux qui
l'ont mené c'est eux qui ont wahabisé
d'abord les musulmans immigrés en Arabie
Saoudite et qui ensuite ont wahabisé les
Égyptiens les Maghrébins et puis le
salafisme est arrivé en France il est
arrivé en France par par les Maghrébins
euh donc il faut laisser à l'Iran sa
juste place et puis on disait il y a
quelques années c'est Gill kpel qui
disait ça il y a le l'axe chiite contre
le croissant chiite contre les accords
d'Abraham donc les Iraniens les Turcs et
les Qataris bah déjà il y a des sunites
et des et des chites et puis en face il
y avait les éériens les saouiens et
Israël ça c'était quand Trump était au
pouvoir et puis Biden est arrivé au
pouvoir et tout ce petit monde c'est
Rabi bché donc il faut il y a pas de
conflit idéologique et religieux au
Proche Orient il y a un conflit
politique il y a un conflit d'intérêt il
y a un conflit y compris de personnes de
gens qui veulent se rester au pouvoir et
qui veulent dominer la région mais il
faut pas tomber dans le piège de leur
discours leur discours c'est souvent des
par avant il y a pas que les discours
parce que si on prend le conflit madame
Bergeot blcler le conflit le dernier
conflit que ce soit à travers le Hamas
ou le Hezbollah ou les
outil quelle place vous attribuez à
l'Iran dans cette conflictualité à la
fois moyenne orientale et mondiale
puisqu'ils armment aussi en partie
l'armée russe contre l'Ukraine je crois
qu'il faut alors ça c'est le problème de
de l'approche politique et politiste en
général c'est de considérer que les
êtres humains sont des êtres assoifffés
de pouvoir et qu'ils ne rêvent que de
pouvoir et qu'il n'y a rien d'autre
évidemment nous les anthropologues on
considère qu'il y a aussi d'autres
dimensions des dimensions symboliques
des dimensions religieuses qui sont très
importantes à comprendre donc c'est pas
étonnant qu'on trouve que les politistes
s'intéressai particulièrement aux état
nation donc pour eux ils sont dans voilà
ils essaient de comprendre les logiques
qui habitent les conf conflit entre état
nation le problème c'est qu'on est dans
un monde mondialisé qu'il a des réseaux
sociaux que aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
en Israël on on le connaît immédiatement
ça produit des manifestations partout en
Europe donc il faut penser il faut se
décaler il faut comprendre que les
états-nationss aujourd'hui sont tenues
par des forces globalisées
nécessairement ça s'appelle les réseaux
sociaux et donc ce qu'on voit au
aujourd'hui avec le le Hamas et Israël
c'est une mondialisation de du du
conflit
israélo-arabe de qui est sur lequel
appui ces réseaux fréristes qui sont
très puissants un peu partout sur les
continents qu'est-ce qu'ils font je je
permettez-moi Youssef El kardaoui quand
il quand il commence à penser en fait
son plan pour les 30 prochaines années
c'était il y a 30 ans qu'est-ce qu'il
dit il dit il faut créer une opinion
publique mondiale c'était quand même
avant les réseaux sociaux il était assez
fort et aujourd'hui on voit que qui qui
appuie qui tire aussi un peu les
ficelles de des conflits dans cette
partie-là ce sont les réseaux sociaux ce
sont les les mosquées de Grande-Bretagne
c'est les les manifestations
gigantesques c'est aussi les pressions
par le marché BDS par exemple le cette
grande organisation qui veut boycotter
les les produits israéliens à une
incidence considérable sur le conflit
donc tout ça je pense qu'il faut le
recomposer et surtout prendre en
considération la dimension religieuse la
dimension de la visée du khalifat pour
ces populationsl c'est il rêve d'une
umama et quand on voit partout sur tous
les continents des manifestations qui
disent Allah Akbar ça veut dire quelque
chose il faut pas le ramener
systématiquement à des conflits de pays
il y a une autre dimension je ne dis pas
que la la dimension territoriale iste
pas mais il y a autre chose qui se joue
oui monsieur di je vis simplement
observer que la recherche d'une d'une
domination idéologique mondiale bah ça a
été de tout temps je veux dire lénine
avait avait un projet
mondial et donc et donc mais c'était au
service
d'ambition politique et nous retrouvons
nous retrouvons avec l'instrument
entalisation des différents courants
islamiques nous retrouvons exactement
c'est quelque chose qui est éternel et
dans le cas du Proche
Orient il y a des ambitions
territoriales il y a des jeux
d'influence qui sont d'ailleurs
changeant alors moi je pense par exemple
que les États-Unis ont fait une erreur
considérable en attaquant l'Irak qui
était un bouclier contre contre l'Iran
et c'était c'était d'ailleurs
l'argumentation française nous avons pas
été écoutés par les États-Unis mais euh
on a on a donné un coup de pied
occidental dans la fourmillère moyen
orientale et maintenant on a les on a
les les dérivations oui kimel caroui
là-dessus oui je pense enfin le Luma
mondial c'est le discours des islamistes
mais c'est pas pour autant que c'est la
vérité que c'est la réalité vous allez
dans les pays pays arabes les pays
musulmans l'identité nationale est très
forte les gens quand il quand ils
manifestent en Tunisie il manifeste pas
pour l'Ouma mondial il manifeste pour le
droit des Palestiniens qui est une sorte
de mythologie politique dans le monde
arabe mais enfin ils sont très tunisiens
euh et les islamistes ont été au pouvoir
en Tunisie ils ont échoué lamentablement
comme ils ont échoué partout où ils ont
été au pouvoir et les identités
nationales se sont construites ce qui
empêche pas qu'il y ait toujours un
discours islamiste global mais le
discours n'est pas la réalité il faut
pas tomber dans le piège du discours
c'est pas parce qu'il y a des gens qui
disentut pas prendre des musulmans et C
c'est pas c'est pas parce qu'ils le
disent que c'est vrai oui c'est pas
parce oui mais enfin il faut pas non
plus les prendre pour des idiots c'està
dire qu'ils ont aussi une parole ce sont
des sujets de l'histoire et donc ne pas
les
écouter cette forme d'arrogance à mon
avis c'est combien de musulmans c'est
combien de musulmans pour vous dans les
chez les musulmans français vous disiez
le frérisme c'est ça idéologie c'est une
idé ça représente qu part des musulmans
français comm 20% 100% vous pouvez pas
évaluer la force d'une idéologie sur une
population il y a des influences moi
j'ai fait une enquête sur les musulmans
sur sur leurs idées leurs comportement
leurs croyances donc je suis arrivé à
une certaine répartition enfin on
pourrait en discuter mais en c'est pas
le lieu de discuter de de votre enquête
et de votre méthodologie non parce que
moi je comprends pas ce qu' que ça nous
amènerait un petit peu voilà donc bah
c'est parce que bah lisez mon livre si
vous voulez comprendre jeai lu avec
grand in mais je voudrais aller alors on
dirait pas en tout cas ce que je pense
c'est que il ne faut pas prendre les
Frères musulmans pour des idiots ni Luma
pour pour le rêve des islamistes ce
n'est pas que le rêve des islamistes
c'est en train de prendre des des formes
la violence du Hamas aujourd'hui cette
violence terrible c'est et pas seulement
la violence mais aussi les crit de joie
qui l'accompagne qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on entend on
on entend allahouakbar on nentend pas
vive la Palestine je veux dire il
faudrait il faut quand même prendre au
sérieux ces ces mouvements de fond- sont
très anciens et qui ont des résonances
histori est-ce que la priorité quand
même pour le Hamas C n'est pas la la
thématique d'Israël des colons et cetera
non et ça c'est intéressant mais c'est
pour ça qu'il faut lire il faut lire les
grands idéologues et kardaoui a été un
grand idéologue très important pour le
Hamas l'objectif c'est vraiment le temps
religieux c'est c'est l'espace religieux
quand il disent ils ne veulent pas
négocier avec Israël ils veulent que
Israël disparaisse et c'est très clair
dans leur charte alors vous allez me
dire oui mais il y a la première charte
il y a la deuxième charte il n'y a pas
de deuxème charte le statut de ce qu'on
appelle la deuxème charte n'est qu'un
document c'est un document politique euh
quand on traduit hein c'est c'est pas du
tout le donc la charte elle est restée
et la Charte ne veut pas de l'existence
d'Israël la charte est profondément
antisémite et son antisémitisme est
profondément ancré dans le texte
religieux alors on peut dire tout ce
qu'on veut on peut dire bi c'est juste
une une
instrumentalisation politique du
religieux mais à penser comme ça on est
passé complètement à côté de la force de
ces mouvements et de l'influence qu'ils
ont aujourd'hui sur les musulmans
d'Europe ce qui ce je m'excuse enfin ce
qui est certain c'est que les tentatives
à l'époque de Trump des accords
d'Abraham donc qui mettait de côté les
les les Palestiniens ont en quelque
sorte
ranimé l'espèce de solidarité était au
proch Orient sur le thème de du du sur
le thèmees religieux moi je pense que je
pense que les Occidentaux actuellement
sont sur la
défensive notamment vis-à-vis des pays
arabes mais pas seulement puisqu'il y a
une instrumentalisation
chinoise russe même même les Indiens
même les Indiens qui qui ne sont pas qui
partag lche pas les les les thèses par
définition chinois puisqu'ils sont
opposés mais même même russe qui qui
joue un espèce de de diplomatie
opportuniste tout ce tout ce ce ce Sud
global a des ambitions de pouvoir
international mais ça passe pas
nécessairement par le Moyen-Orient et ça
passe pas nécessairement par les
idéologies oui alors écoutez moi je
voudrais bon il y a des dissonances mais
c'est c'est le débat mais Hakim elkoui
je voudrais partir d'une réflexion de
Churchill qui disait vous verrez que les
guerres des peuples seront autrement
plus redoutables que les guerres des
nations et des états-ntions on y est
non aujourd'hui non après si vous
regardez l'ire vous regardez les
chiffres vous regardez le nombre de
morts en fait les guerres des
étatsnationss sont effroyablement plus
graves et plus létales que les guerres
des peuples ou les guerres des idées euh
enfin s'il y a pas la le bras armé de
l'État naation le bras armé de de l'
enfin le du système militaire
euh on va pas rester sur le proche
orient puisqu'on va aborder d'autres
sujets mais
manifestement avec des états les
problèmes se règlent tandis que hors des
états les problèmes ne se règlent pas
non je suis pas d'accord enfin les États
les problèmes se règlent par la guerre
se règl avec d'autres outils d'analyse
oui mais regarde parce que la vi vous
avez évoqué la violence à de Lénine mais
Lénine aujourd'hui un historien comme
kercha par exemple britannique qui est
au-delà de toute critique extrémiste il
serait même plutôt à gauche il considère
que le pouvoir a été conquis par la
violence pour la violence et que y avait
pas il y avait il n a pas il y a pas qu'
l'époque de
Lénine Napoléon a a qui le pouvoir par
un coup d'État et qui était par
définition de l'utilisation d'une
violence circonscrite certes mais non
oui mais ça revient dans l'actualité
c'est aujourd'hui qui qui a aidé Israël
au moment de son indépendance c'était
c'était la Russe l'Union soviétique via
les tchèqus qui on envoyé des armes
aujourd'hui la
Russie s'it avec les anti-israéliens
donc donc si vous voulez on peut pas
c'est pas idéologique c'est simplement
de
l'opportunisme
diplomatique bien il y a aucune
idéologie derrière tout
[Musique]
ça bon pour revenir un peu dans le cadre
de notre
émission est-ce que vous pensez que les
valeurs démocratiques celles qui sont
issues des lumières est-ce qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui en danger et est-ce que ce
Sud
global au-delà de ses
intérêts divers veut mettre en cause les
valeurs occidentales les valeurs des
lumières Patrick kess difficile de
répondre oui ou non parce que sommes pas
dans une situation de de ce type mais il
est certain qu'on est dans une
phase fort compliquée et où on voit très
bien comment se décompose un certain
nombre de valeurs sur lesquelles ont été
fondé les les principes républicains les
lumières des choses qui sont évidentes
quand on les
ressasse dans des articles quand on les
ressasse à la télévision ça paraît
évident et pourtant on sent bien que
c'est pas du tout évident en ce moment
c'est même profondément
menacé on est dans dans un contexte on
voit bien que les les principes des
lumières sont
aujourd'hui fortement contesté et par
des gens qui ne se positionnent pas
clairement d'ailleurs sur ces sur ces
sujets donc c'était ça la question mais
la question elle est est-ce que les
valeurs démocratiques auquelles nous
sommes attachés qui
régissent le monde occidental est-ce que
ces valeurs son sont en danger bien
sûr mais si je peux me permettre bien sr
pas seulement Leal qui les met en danger
regardez ce qui se passe aux États-Unis
on a quand même eu aux États-Unis une
tentative de coup d'état par le
président sortant euh pour moi la plus
grave menace pour la démocratie
aujourd'hui en tout cas légal de la
Russie c'est les États-Unis les
États-Unis eux-mêmes le retour de Trump
et au-delà du retour de Trump la
polarisation du débat entre la gauche W
qui devient totalement irraisonné euh la
droite conservatrice qui à l'évidence
n'adhère plus aux valeurs de la
démocratie libérale donc si vous voulez
c'est pas seulement le sud global c'est
aussi nous avons une contestation de la
démocratie en Europe même à l'intérieur
de l'Union européenne qui s'est fondé
sur des sur sur les valeurs sur les
valeurs occidentales et sur les valeurs
des lumières enfin je veux dire quand
même l'Union européenne c'était c'était
c'était un c'était pas seulement c'était
pas seulement le le libre marché
économique c'était véritablement des
valeurs aujourd'hui nous avons des gens
en Autriche en en
Slovaquie au Pays-Bas récemment en
Hongrie et et dans le et en Pologne avec
le gouvernement précédent qui conteste
ouvertement un certain nombre de valeurs
que nous considérons comme essentiell
alors pour réagir qu'est-ce que nous
avons nous leur disons ben vous ne
bénéficierez pas des crédits de l'Union
européenne alors c'est quand même c'est
quand même une question difficile et je
suis pas sûr que ça soit efficace pour
eux et donc nous avons alors aux
États-Unis nous avons nous avons une
division profonde du pays mais qui qui
est accentué par le
communautarisme mais qui n'est pas
seulement dû au communautarisme c'est
une et je et je pense que cette division
des de la société américaine elle est
elle est très périlleuse pour la défense
de nos valeurs occidentales tout
simplement parce que les États-Unis ont
représenté pendant longtemps un espèce
de phare occidentale bon
aujourd'hui l'Occident c'est pas
seulement les États-Unis c'est aussi
l'Union européenne et et d'autres pays
sur d'autres continents qui qui qui sont
qui adhèrent pas forcément à notre
système notre républicain et au aux
formes institutionnelles de nos valeurs
mais qui partage quand même un certain
nombre
d'idées qui qui sont proches disons de
l'héritage des lumière oui madame
Bergeot black là-dessus oui on
rapidement d'abord je je ne connais pas
le l'origine de de cette expression le
sud global je ne sais pas exactement à
quoi ça correspond est-ce que ça
correspond vous savez c'est une j'allais
dire c'est une création médiatique VO
voilà bon en tout je m'excuse non ce
sont les bricks qui étaient des
puissances économiques qui montaient qui
ont décidé qu'elles n'étaient pas bien
représenté dans le système international
et puis ensuite c'est ils ont voulu le
globaliser ils ont pris des des pays qui
qui ne sont pas des puissan économi
voilà c'est une c'est une réalité voilà
de
géostratégicoéconomique bon par contre
ce qui est intéressant aujourd'hui c'est
le le mouvement décolonialistes le
mouvement décolonial dont le qui est une
partie du wokisme qui effectivement fait
parler ce Sud global sans sans en être
et qui joue un rôle très important
justement dans notre représentation du
monde avec les démocraties les non
démocraties enfin un nouveau
tiermondisme en réalité qui fait que ces
mouvements antidémocratiques de nos
sociétés européennes riches et
d'abondance aujourd'hui se se positionne
ou parle au nom de ces nations-l ce qui
est ce qui est une autre forme
d'arrogance je parlais d'arrogance tout
à l'heure et on se retrouve
effectivement avec une avec des analyses
de qui qui sont produites par ce par ce
ce
wokisme qui qui dessine un Sud dominant
antilumière et qui finit par faire la
promotion
d'idéologie comme celle de de
l'islamisme dont on parlait qui sont
profondément antidémocratiques donc
c'est pas que les pays du Sud soient
antidémocratiqu et soit contre le nord
c'est que aussi il faut savoir qui qui
parle du Sud et et est-ce qu'on ne le
fait pas parler je crois pas pardon je
crois pas que les décoloniaux parlent
beaucoup du Sud global qui parlent du
Brésil qui parl de l'Inde qui parle de
l'Afrique du Sud qui parle de la Chine
ben vous c'est parce que vous connaissez
pas les des coloniauxx ah bon ok en
sentend on avait parlé d'un conflit des
des civilisations bon
aujourd'hui comment on peut
appréhender ce qui se passe parce que
manifestement vous avez de nouvelles
alliances qui se créent et est-ce que
vous trouvez pas que les Occidentaux
sont là à se culpabiliser à se fl gélé
parce que finalement prendre sa place
dans le concert mondial on l' prend par
l'économie on l' prend par la création
culturelle on l'prend par les valeurs
initiées sur le plan politique et et
donc on la prend par la
puissance la puissance supporte
encourage l'influence bon parce que vous
avez cette manière de se flagéler
aujourd'hui en disant on leur a pas
laissé la place mais il y a pas laisser
la place pr place moi moi moi je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui ne se
flagellent pas il a
je nous nous constatons qu'il y a
actuellement une une l'idée l'idée d'une
guerre idéologique mondiale c'est ça ça
dérive de des analyses d'untington et
cetera et qui était opposé à l'époque au
même moment à une autre idéologie
c'était le triomphe de la démocratie
universelle
il faut faut quand même se souvenir des
débats et des gens des des Français
comme Pierre Asner par exemple avait
complètement démonté déjà cette ces
conceptions et reconnaissait comme
Kissinger que c'est la puissance y
compris militaire et économique qui
finalement euh fait pencher les bascules
et actuellement qu'est-ce que nous avons
nous avons des États-Unis qui jouent un
rôle moindre parce qu'ils sont ils ne
veulent pas s'engager autant dans dans
dans le monde parce qu'ils ont eu des
échecs l'Afghanistan le départ des des
forces américaines
d'Afghanistan ça a été quand même très
très impressionnant pour les les gens du
Sud
global ça comment les Américains depuis
le Vietnam ne veulent plus perdre des
leur jeunes dans dans des conflits et
donc actuellement nous avons euh nous et
et l'Europe n'est pas en mesure de
compenser parce que c'est de de jouer un
rôle de de rééquilibre alors elle le
cherche mais elle n'a pas elle n'a pas
les moyens en plus si vous ajoutez le
vieillissement démographique de
l'Europe on n pas des on n pas une force
qui est très active mais je pense que il
y a une prise de conscience du fait que
nos valeurs sont menacées que la
démocratie est est menacée cela dit on
ne va pas faire comme la l'avait proposé
Madeleine Albright une conférence des
démocraties et une organisation des
démocraties parce que il suffit de de
voir qui on va inviter est-ce que l'Inde
aujourd'hui qui est plutôt
prooccidental est une démocratie
certainement pas avec Monsieur
maudi bien oui revenir parce que j'étais
unu làdessus mais al soyez un peu concis
parce qu'il nous reste très peu de temps
et donc on va conclure en fait la
fabrique du décolonialisme aujourd'hui
c'est les universités et c'est tout
c'est tout à fait intéressant les
universités
ou les centres de recherche nous on a
des étudiants qui sont systématiquement
opposés à tout ce qui provient de
l'Europe donc ils se mettent à la place
des Indiens se mettent à la place des
Brésiliens se mettent à la place des
Chinois et cetera ça c'est c'est ces
états ne leur posent aucun problème même
s'ils sont s'ils ont des pratiques
antidémocratiques et c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui une
bonne partie de notre représentation du
monde est produite par ces ces jeunes
ces étudiants qui qu'on appelle des
coloniaux ou wistes donc vous parlez
d'un noyau faut les connaître à
l'univers un mot là-dessus on conclut
hein oui moi je pense qu'il faut
quantifier qu'il ait des mouvements
minoritaires revendicatif au
revendicateur oui mais évidemment que ça
a toujours existé d'extrême gauche
aujourd'hui il y en a de plus en plus
d'extrême droite ça a toujours existé
euh le sujet c'est quel est l'équilibre
et puis quel est quel quelle est la
dynamique aussi je pense pas qu'il
faillit avoir peur outre mesure des
mouvements minoritaires ce qui compte
c'est la dynamique majoritaire et je
crois pas que les Occidentaux se
flagèent certains aimeraient bien qu'ils
se flagèent certains à l'intérieur de
l'Occident les décoloniaux aimeraient
qu'ils se flagèent mais je vois aucun
gouvernement occidental aujourd'hui qui
se flagèle et qui en fa qui en fait un
un axe politique pas du tout oui un mot
pour conclure Patrick Kessel vous pensez
qu'il y a un malaise des civilisations
la dessus vous l'utiliserez plutôt qu'un
qu'un conflit de civilisation je pas
siil y a malaise des civilisations il y
a adéiablement un malaise
global face auquel nos gouvernants d'où
qu'il soi ont bien du mal à prendre le
problème bras le corps on sent
aujourd'hui les les tergiversations les
besoins se justifiés les besoin de mais
tout ça c'est du c'est de la poudre aux
yeux quoi on est on est dans un vide
sidéral en terme de perspective
politique voilà ben écoutez puisque
l'émission arrive à son terme je
voudrais vous présenter une brève
bibliographie alors Madame Florence
Bergeot blackler vous avez écrit le
frérisme et ses réseaux l'enquête avec
une préface de Gilles kpel mais en deux
mots pour les gens qui n'ont pas lu
votre livre vous avez voulu montrer quoi
ce que c'était que le frérisme cette
idéologie qu'elle est plus puissante
qu'on ne le croit qu'elle est difficile
à voir mais qu'on peut quand même la
combattre et elle a des racine à la fois
historique et contemporaine tout à fait
tout à fait Himel cararoui vous êtes
penché là-dessus puisque vous avez écrit
les militants du djihad portrait d'une
génération est-ce que ce livre que vous
avez publié il y a quelques années vous
pensez qu'il a pris quelques rides
aujourd'hui ou on vous le cignerez
aujourd'hui de la même manière il
portait sur la génération des années
2010 de la la Syrie les militants
djihadistes qui sont partis en Syrie et
puis les ce qui ce qui s'est produit
après en France Charlie le le Bataclan
et cetera aujourd'hui c'est plus
exactement les mêmes les terroristes en
France hein c'est plutôt des individus
isolés qui sont moins organisés qui sont
pas dirigés par des forces extérieures
après sur l'analyse non et enfin
l'intért je crois de cette analyse
c'était qu'elle était quantifiée c'était
vraiment une analyse qui était fondée
sur une base de données et donc on avait
des grands nombres 700 djihadistes
français 1500 au total pour essayer de
comprendre vu vu d'hélicoptère d'une
certaine manière les dynamiques sociales
personnel et puis les dynamiques
d'engagement et aussi les dynamiques
idéologiques bien sûr alors Patrick
Kessel Marianne toujours c'est votre
combat républicain d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui ça veut dire Marian
toujours oui ça veut dire dire que si on
en feuillette les livres de nos
prédécesseurs on se rend compte que la
question demeure de la laïcité de la
liberté de conscience et qu'on y voit
sortir de ça et que ceux qui ont voulu
en sortir se sont grandement trompés on
a besoin aujourd'hui de retrouver les
valeurs sûres de trouver des gens qui et
pour vous c'est la laïcité républicaine
bah pour moi c'est sans aucun doute le
je dirais le le fondement
d'un d'un
complément pour être ensemble
c'est-à-dire être capable de vivre
ensemble ça veut dire être capable
de de de se retrouver dans dans des
valeurs dans des principes qui ne sont
pas fondés sur la haine de l'autre sur
l'affrontement auquel on assiste de plus
en plus on le voit avec la situation au
Proche Orient mais c'est véritablement
la nécessité aujourd'hui de trouver un
espace
complémentaire de complémentarité et qui
permett aujourd'hui d'avancer sur ce
sujet P qu'on est pas au bout de nos
peines merci alors Benoît daabovi je
pense voulez parler d'un livre qui
a Syvie Koffman journaliste
éditorialiste au Monde a
publié un livre tout à fait intéressant
dans le contexte actuel qui montre come
Poutine a en quelque
sorte avancé ses pions en geéorgie
d'abord en Ukraine aujourd'hui et que
ceci a été fait avec une avec une
réaction européenne notamment de la part
de de Madame Merkel et de Macron où qui
n'ont pas tout à qui n'ont pas tout à
fait au bon moment saisi les
opportunités où nous aurions pu réagir
et je trouve que c'est très intéressant
c'est très vivant ce sont des
témoignages qu'elle a recueilli et ça
nous met véritablement dans la politique
active des états c'est pas du tout
l'idéologie c'est véritablement
de la bataille diplomatique avec des
avancées des reculs et des et nous avons
certainement perdu euh notamment en
raison de de de la puissance disons du
lobby pro Poutine pro pro allemand pour
des raisons économiques en Allemagne
nous avons quand même perdu des années
et maintenant on se retrouve avec
l'Ukraine et c'est un problème très
difficile pour nous tous car si Poutine
gagne nous perdons merci écoutez je
voudrais merci Madame merci messieurs
d'avoir participer à cette émission je
voudrais remercier notre équipe de LCP
qui a permis sa sa réalisation et avant
de nous quitter je vous laisse avec
cette citation de Philippe diribarn
l'islam est dès l'origine un mouvement
politico-rigieux le fait que les mœurs
de l'Occident soi si peu marqués par des
impératif religieux tant à le faire
regarder globalement comme impi rendant
impi toute allégeance à son
[Musique]
égard